five in the morning is that the
conservatives have now passed the
finishing post they have won a majority
in this campaign and that is the
informal result for us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as you can see we've won before and now
we need to deliver a strategy to win
again
nine years ago before i was a minister
and long before i became chairman i was
a 40-40 targeted
in just two years
and to let people know about the
important work that we're still doing
creating jobs investing in public
services and improving lives
and that's what the 8020 target campaign
is all about
this is
every single member
this campaign will take place over two
years
[Music]
we've got new campaign managers across
the country helping mps tell their
stories
the first leaflet of the 8020 campaign
is hitting doors this summer
and over the next two years
out we can win the next generation
in the meantime
we've got two excellent candidates and
they're both clearly ready to be the
prime minister
no matter which channel that you choose
let's remember the country will be
making a choice two years from now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
and
is
over the next two years
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening team southwest
this is the second hustings in our
national tour
and for me it's good to be here on my
home territory in our great south west
thank you all for attending this evening
and it's good to see so many friends and
colleagues in the audience
these hustings are for us the members of
the party
to take part in a great exercise of
democracy
where we get to choose our new leader
he or she will be announced on the 5th
of september
and as with the party of government then
we'll become prime minister very soon
after
as ian dale who moderated many of these
hustings in 2019 said and i quote
i found sharing the hustling is a
surprisingly positive experience
the members really put the two
candidates through their paces
and asked some very certain questions
so i asked tonight
that you make your questions searching
make them succinct and ask questions and
not make statements and one question
each please so that more of the audience
here have a chance to ask questions
both of our candidates have a duty and a
desire to fulfill our 2019 manifesto
their differences will be about how to
go about achieving that in a very
different world from 2019 which is
post-brexit post-code in uncertain times
internationally and where our union as a
nation is being challenged
so i'm sure that you want to test our
candidates and to seek to establish
their strengths
and to see who you think is best capable
of running our great country
as we're all conservatives i know that
you'll be respectful of our two
candidates and keep your questions
positive
for them for me and our cchq team
who have worked so diligently to set up
these hustlings at short notice and in
mid-summer
these hustlings run on a tight schedule
until the 31st of august when we have
our last final rally in london
as you know our ballot opens soon
you can cast your vote online or by post
we ask that where possible you can cast
your vote online
quite simply it costs us less and i'm
sure that we want our hard-earned funds
to go into campaigning
so my hope is that this evening will
give you much more clarity about how to
cast your vote
i hope that you all go away enthused and
energized in your commitment to helping
our party win the next election
we need your help and support
finally i'd like to thank our southwest
regional chairman julian ellicott for
all the work that he does on our behalf
julian you do a great job
i hope very much
i hope very much that you enjoy your
evening
please welcome the financial times white
hall editor and best-selling author
payne
[Applause]
well good evening everyone and as you
just heard my name's sebastian payne i'm
white or editor of financial times and
i've written a book which i'm going to
try and mention as many times as
possible this evening and for those of
you who buy the financial times well
thank you you're paying my salary and
you'll be very well aware i've written a
lot about the conservative party but
also this contest and for those of you
who don't need the financial times well
i'm sorry for you and i would strongly
advise you do there's some great
subscription offers online to get lots
of news
this is the second hosting of the 2022
conservative leadership election i hope
to stand on the shoulders of nick
ferrari and all my other fellow
journalists who have um hosted such
events now we've got a lot to get
through and in the spirit of
southwestern hospitality i'm certain
it's going to be very warm well it
certainly is warm and friendly evening
this is how things will run for our pair
of contenders we'll hear from their
supporters see some no doubt about their
snazzy introduction videos before their
speeches and then i'll be asking them
some questions but the core this evening
is you the party members with the weight
of choosing the next uk prime minister
on your shoulders i want to get to as
many of your questions as possible so do
keep them short
to the point and if possible please put
a question mark at the end of them
there will be roving helpers with
microphones to go around the hall to get
them we get to that point but that's
enough for me you're not here to listen
to a journalist bang on so please
welcome to the stage our first speaker
for this evening the right honourable
pen and board mp
[Applause]
please welcome penny mordons
well thank you ladies and gentlemen the
feeling is entirely mutual
thank you so much for being here tonight
the fact that so many of you are is
testament to
how every single one of you cares deeply
about the task that's been afforded to
us
this isn't just about one person
it's about all of us
and i know it's not easy
you feel a huge responsibility
i do too
that is the price i'm afraid of
democracy
if we get this decision wrong
we'll shortchange the country
we may lose an election
and everything that we have worked for
will be gone
that's why this matters so much
why you feel that responsibility and why
i do too and why
i'm here with you this evening
i could have
remained
undeclared
i could be off sipping pina coladas
right now but i'm not
i'm here with you
because this
this is too important
and i'm i'm not going to leave this to
chance
and nor will you
i came third in this contest
and i owe it
to all of you
to be a signpost not a weather ban
and so i've made my choice
and i know it's difficult
because i like both candidates
they are both
good conservatives who love their
country
and they've both done what they thought
was right for the right reasons
i want to say nice things about both of
them
which is probably why i came third
i know that choosing between them is
hard
but this contest is a test
a test that precedes an even greater
test
so who can lead
who can build that team and deliver for
our
country who does have that bold economic
plan that our nation needs
who's got reach who can relate to people
who understands that people need help
with the cost of living now
and who
is going to
rightly clobber our opponents
who is going to hold seats and win back
councils
and who
most embodies
the vision and values the british public
had in their heads and their hearts when
they voted in 2016 and 2019.
at the start of this final phase of the
contest i didn't know the answer to
those questions
but i've seen enough to know
who the person i'm going to put my faith
in is
and that is liz truss
her graft
her authenticity
her determination her ambition for this
country
her consistency and sense of duty she
knows what she believes in
and her
resolve to stand up
against tyranny
and fight for freedom
that's what our country stands for and
that's why i know with her
we can win
and actually
seeing her
over the last few weeks
has made me want to help her
to help her win
to help build the team we need to win
the country
and to give ourselves as a party
and as a nation the pride and the
confidence we need to reach
our full potential
in short folks
to give us all hope
she for me is the hope candidate
and that is why i am here tonight
to be straight with all of you and to
tell you that my choice in this contest
to lead us and our nation
is liz truss
thank
is a great you
and i know that the united conservative
party can unleash the potential of all
the people who make our country so great
to win the next election we need to
deliver deliver
and deliver
[Music]
japan creating opportunities around the
world
and as prime minister i will continue to
deliver on the opportunities
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
please welcome liz truss
oh
it's fantastic to be here in exeter
and it's fantastic to have the support
of penny mordent
she's a great person she's a great
politician she's a great patriot and i'm
proud to call her my friend
now i remember
back in 2015
sways of the southwest were under the
control of a dark force
the liberal democrats
and i remember going out there on the
streets
to the farm shops to the farms
to the cornish pasty factories i turned
out not to be very good at crimping
cornish pasties but with you know great
candidates
like kevin foster like scott man like
jdtp
and i remember how hard we worked
there were long hours and long days i
remember a particular afternoon at
sheppy's cider very very difficult work
but somebody had to do it
but what we did
what we did
is we rooted those liberal democrats out
of the south west
their
fake bar charts
their euro love
their high taxes
and we made sure we won for the
conservatives and what i want to tell
you
as your prime minister first of all i
would win back tibbetted and committed
and secondly
secondly
i would never ever ever
i would never ever ever allow them to
encroach in the south west again
because ladies and gentlemen
i'm a fighter
i think you come from a traditional
conservative background
i grew up in paisley
and in leeds where i went to a
comprehensive school
and i remember children at my school
being let down
they were let down by low expectations
they were let down by a lack of
opportunity and they were let down by
the left-wing lead city council
who cared more about political
correctness than making sure everybody
could read and write
and that made me
want to do something about the appalling
waste of talent in this country
i wanted things to be better
and i believe that everybody should be
able to succeed regardless of where
they're from regardless of their
background
i want us to be an aspiration nation
and that's why i'm standing to be your
prime minister
but we need to be honest
we do face difficult times
we have the economic crisis after covert
we have the appalling war perpetrated by
vladimir putin in ukraine
now is not the time for business as
usual
now we have to be bold we need a plan
for growth and that is what i will do
first of all i'll unleash all of the
opportunities of brexit from investment
to procurement
i will get all of those eu laws off our
statute books by the end of 2023
and i will replace them making us more
dynamic more competitive and more ready
to attract investment
i'll reverse the increase in national
insurance
we should have kept our manifesto
commitment
and we didn't need to do it
and i think it is wrong when families
are struggling to pay their bills to put
up their taxes
i'd always say
i'd also have a temporary moratorium on
the green levy
so people see an immediate reduction
in immediate reduction
an immediate reduction in their fuel
bills
because i know
that people are struggling with the cost
of living
and i want to be on the side of people
who go out to work who do the right
thing who are self-employed who set up
small businesses those are the people we
as conservatives should be on the side
of
and i will also keep corporation tax low
i think it's wrong
that we are planning to raise
corporation tax to the same level as
france
last time i looked france was not a
low-tax country
and we need we need to keep our economy
competitive
we need to attract investment right
across this country but we need to
particularly attract it
into places like the south west of
england
now i believe in leveling up but
leveling up for me is not just about the
north
it's also about our rural communities
it's about helping people who don't have
the best infrastructure where it's hard
to get a mobile phone signal whether
broadband doesn't work those are the
[Applause]
investment rules and make sure it's fair
because you all know that the services
are better in london than the south east
than they are here and we need to change
that
i also want to have
low tax investment zones
where we can unleash opportunity and we
can build more homes for local people
going to local jobs to give people
opportunities here in the southwest
now
before i became an mp
i was a counselor
and as part of my job as a counselor i
sat on the planning committee
and i can tell you those are hours of my
life that i will never get back
because
we all know
that you sit there making those
decisions and you get overruled by
somebody in bristol
or you get a top-down housing target
from whitehall i will abolish those
top-down targets and i will give local
people control of what happens in their
area
i will also
i will also back our farmers
i want our farmers producing food we
know how difficult the global situation
is
we need food security
farmers should be getting on with
farming not having to fill in forms not
having to comply with all kinds of rules
and regulations
and our fields
should be full of our fantastic produce
you know whether it's the great
livestock the great arable farms it
shouldn't be full of solar panels and i
will change the rules
to make sure to make sure we're using
our high-value agricultural land for
farming
and what i will also do is i will back
our fishermen
now in 2026
there is going to be a new negotiation
and i will make sure as an independent
coastal state
we have full control over our fishing
waters
and you know
you know
that i am the person who will be tough
on the eu
i took on the northern ireland protocol
negotiations we didn't get what we
needed for the eu
i developed the northern ireland
protocol bill we secured the majority in
parliament we will get it through we
will sort out that issue and we will be
on the side of our fishermen
i will also
i will also continue to stand up for
vladimir putin now i
put in place the toughest sanction
regime on russia
i also worked with my colleagues to make
sure we were the first european country
supplying weapons to ukraine
but we can't rest on our laurels we need
to make sure
we need to make sure
that our defense spending is in line
with the threat which has increased
so i will raise defense spending to 3 of
gdp by the end of the decade i'll back
our armed services and i'll make sure
i'll make sure
i'll make sure that our veterans are
protected i will also tackle the issue
of small base in the english channel
i worked with pretty patel on the rwanda
deal i want to do more deals like that
and i will legislate in britain to make
sure the echr cannot overrule
our policy to tackle illegal immigration
but as well as freedom and democracy
abroad we need it here at home and i'm a
straight talking yorkshire woman i know
a woman is a woman
you might laugh but that's become a
controversial statement in some parts of
britain today
i will protect single sex spaces such as
domestic violence shelter and i will
make sure that we stand up for the
united kingdom and we're proud of our
history not just standing up for it
overseas but also rejecting the
naysayers and declining
who say that our country's best days are
behind us they're not our best days are
in front of it and that is what i will
deliver as your prime minister
i know that we can deliver i know we can
get things done i will channel the
spirit and i was at wembley last night
watching the lionesses i will channel
the spirit of the lionesses who fought
bravely against the odds and got things
done and delivered a massive massive
victory and that's what we can do that's
what we can do for the united kingdom as
we unlock our potential against the
plastic patriot
and that is what we can do from the
conservative party because people who
voted conservative from the blue wall to
the red wall to cornwall they voted
conservative
because they wanted conservative
policies not because they wanted higher
taxes not because they wanted labor
light they voted for us because they
believe in our values and we have to
have that confidence in ourselves and
that is what i will deliver as your
prime minister thank you very much
thank you very much and everyone that
was obviously liz trust and penny morgan
now on to the third speaker for this
evening and please welcome to the stage
the right honourable dr liam fox mp
[Applause]
well good evening everyone
when he was still prime minister
and i was defense secretary i was on a
plane with david cameron going to
afghanistan
and we were discussing the conservative
party he said
liam i regard myself as a liberal
conservative how do you regard yourself
and i thought this could be career
defining this particular ancestor i said
well david i regard myself as an
unreconstructed free-market thatcherite
unionist eurosceptic attack
there was something of a pause as you
can imagine
after that but i know what sort of
conservative i am as you will know what
sort of conservatives you are
and i know what sort of leader i want
as leader of our party i want someone
who believes in sound money who
understands the value of small
businesses who believes in strong
defence who values the union of the
united kingdom and not only believed in
but campaigned for brexit
but it's not just policy that this
election
is out about of course but it's about
character
being prime minister means taking tough
decisions even when you're unpopular mrs
thatcher once said to me my dear that's
what you have saying my dear if you want
to be popular go into light
entertainment you said politics is
entirely the wrong career for you
as ever i can quite listen
in the pandemic rishi sunak took
difficult
but vital decisions
how many jobs would we have lost
how many businesses would not still be
afloat had it not been for the furlough
scheme that the imf said was the best in
the world
and character is also
and character is also about the team you
build around you from william hague and
michael howard to some of the best of
the 2019 intake here tonight rishi has
understood one thing that we all should
understand about our party and that is
we avoid external coalitions by
maintaining an internal coalition all
our best leaders have understood that
and that is why we've been the most
successful political party in the
western world
but there is one key issue that all of
us need to think about tonight and in
the next few weeks
i spent
all of the 13 miserable years in
opposition
on the front bench
i don't want to go back there
to win a general election
it's not about persuading people like me
or you
it's actually about persuading those
swing voters who we need to make a
difference and we will have to stop an
snp labour coalition from literally
tearing our nation apart if we don't win
the next general election
we will need a leader and a prime
minister with the right policies yes
but with character
with courage
with experience
and with intellect
and the downright decency to swing those
voters behind us and get them to look
conservative i believe ladies and
gentlemen
that that leader that prime minister
would be rishi sunnah
[Applause]
[Music]
my values
traditional conservative values are
clear
hard work
patriotism
fairness
a love of family
pragmatism
belief that we can build a better
a thriving future economy
[Music]
please
good evening
thank you
thank you
thank you everyone thank you
thank you good evening everyone it's
fantastic to be with you it's also great
to be out and about in the southwest
over the last couple of days meeting all
our members having lots of conversations
and in fact taking lots of selfies too
but i've got to be honest with you
i'm never happier when one of our
members asked me to take a photo with
one of their kids
honestly i think finally a photo with
someone my own size
hello i'm here tonight standing in front
of you for one very simple reason
and that's because this country our
country did something extraordinary for
my family by welcoming them here as
immigrants 60 years ago and allowing
them to build a better life because
that's what our amazing country does
now i was raised with a set of values
that are core to who i am
and first among those is that family
means everything to me
because the bonds of family
are far greater than anything any
government could ever hope to replicate
and we must never ever forget
now in that
in my family we prioritized hard work
because that was the way that you forged
ahead my dad was an nhs gp
you might have heard that my mom ran a
local chemist in southampton
i spent my time working there delivering
medicines to people who couldn't get
them in
but i also did her books her payroll her
back and saw the transformative
opportunity that a small business like
that could provide in our community
now for my parents the way that they
wanted to build a better future for
their three children was simple
and it was through education
and i passionately believe even now that
the best way to reduce inequality the
best way to spread opportunity
indeed the best way to transform lives
is through education
so that so those in a nutshell are my
values patriotism
service
family hard work aspiration and looking
out at all of you i'm sure they are your
values too because those are
conservative values and mine is a
conservative story
that is why i want to be your next
leader and next prime minister because i
want to translate those conservative
values into action in government to
build a better britain and with your
support
i know
that we can build a britain where the
birthright of every child is a
world-class education
a britain which leads the world in
standards of integrity decency and
leadership
of britain built
on aspiration hard work and hope
and of britain where we can be
enormously proud of our history and
confident about our future
but before we get there we have to
tackle three immediate challenges
we have to restore trust
we have to rebuild the economy
and we have to reunite our country
now to restore trust we have to start by
being honest and as you can see in this
leadership race
i've not taken the easy path because our
country faces some challenges and i want
to be straight with all of you and the
country about those and what is going to
be required to grapple with them
it may not be easy but it is honest and
that is what leadership is about
but we also restore trust by delivering
on the things that matter to people
and that's why i've set out a plan to
radically
challenge consensus and reform the nhs
so we can focus less on how much we put
into it and more about what we get out
of it and cut those backlogs
it's why i want to make sure
that the government in westminster
understands the needs of rural
communities like mine in north yorkshire
and yours here and that means making
sure our fields are used for food
production and not solar panels
it means
it means prioritizing our fishing
communities it means backing our farmers
and food security
that's how you can store trust in the
system
but crucially
that's why i've also set out a plan to
finally grip and resolve the issue of
the legal migration because for far too
long we have all watched those scenes on
our tv screens and it must stop and with
my plan with radical measures novel
thinking we will finally get to grips
resolve that problem and have proper
control of our borders because that's
how you restore trust back in the system
now now when it comes to rebuilding the
economy
you all know what the biggest challenge
we face is and that is inflation
and you also all know
that inflation is the enemy that makes
everyone poorer it reduces living
standards
it erodes people's hard earned savings
and pensions it pushes up mortgage rates
and of course i want to help people with
the cost of living and that's why this
autumn we will cut v-18 on energy bills
but i'm not going to do things that risk
making the problem far worse
and
last far longer especially
if that
means borrowing tens of billions of
pounds in unfunded promises
which we just put on the country's
credit card and then ask our children
and grandchildren to pick up the tab
but i am
gonna cut taxes and that's why today i
set out a radical set of reforms to cut
the basic rate of income tax by a fifth
under my leadership because as
conservatives we believe in hard work i
want to reward hard work and allow
people to keep more of their hard-earned
money so under me income taxes will fall
and they will fall at the fastest rate
since nigel lawson and margaret thatcher
so we're going to do that responsibly
we're not going to ask our kids to pay
for it we're going to do it by being
tough on public spending reforming
public services and by growing the
economy because this autumn i want to
reform our business taxes so we cut
taxes for those businesses that are
actually investing in the economy that
are growing the economy that are
innovating
and i want to take advantage of all our
brexit freedoms as chancellor i embarked
on a radical policy of freeport we're
going to have one in plymouth and you
know why because leveling up is not just
about the north it's about the south
west too
and i want to bring that same radicalism
across government i want to form
regulations in agriculture and financial
services and data and life sciences so
that we can make this the best country
in the world for companies to start and
grow
because in a 21st century economy that's
what you need to do and my experience
means i am the best person to lead our
economy into that future and seize the
opportunities that are there waiting for
us
but lastly we have to reunite our
country
and in just a couple of years we have to
do something that's never been done
before and that's to win a fifth
election victory
we have to make british political
history in doing that
but i know we can do it i know we can do
it working together
and you know where it starts
it starts
with winning back tivoton and holiday
but that's not going to be enough we
need to appeal to swing voters
everywhere here in the south west in
london in cheshire and amisham in brexit
supporting t-side in wales and in
scotland
and i passionately believe and the
evidence shows that i am the candidate
that gives our party the best
opportunity of beating kieran and
ensuring labour never win that election
and in conclusion i'll just say this
as chancellor you saw me in the pandemic
you saw me act
boldly
radically quickly ripping up the
rulebook to ensure that we protected
millions of jobs and businesses
supported the economy made sure it was
resilient got through the worst
recession in 300 years and bounced back
strongly on the other side
and as your prime minister i will bring
that same energy that same grip to all
the challenges that we face tackling
illegal migration reforming our public
services growing our economy putting
those conservative values into action
and i also promise you this
i will give you my everything my heart
and soul into making sure that each and
every one of you here tonight
can feel enormously proud of the
conservative government that i will be
privileged to lead so i humbly ask
for your support not just to be our next
party leader but also the next prime
minister of our great country thank you
right ladies and gentlemen i'm back
again and we are now here for the
fireside chat element or maybe it should
be a firepit chat element given that it
is the summer here now you've had lots
to think about from those speeches there
some things you may have heard before
some new things as well i want you to
percolate on those questions while i'm
having my moment with each of our
candidates here so when you do your
questions i'm sure you all want to ask
about taxes europe i have seen some
conservative party events before but
maybe you could be a little bit more
imaginative and think of some different
potential topics particularly with
regards to the southwest that we could
talk about but we'll come to that in
about 10 minutes and you will see around
the room some white hoodie people they
could wave at one moment you'll see
where they'll be going around and will
grab the questions when we come to that
but before that i'd like to be in with
my bit when i get to chapter canada so
please give a warm welcome to bring back
to the stage the right honourable liz
trust mp
so shall we begin with your big new
surprise endorsement that came this
evening penny mordent and i think some
people might have seen that and being
perhaps a bit surprised because i
believe that some of your supporters
were not the biggest fans of penny
morton's one of them and they had their
great reservations about her running for
her candidacy another accused of maybe
being a little bit workshop do you have
any great reservations about her i think
freddie mordent
is a brilliant person a fantastic
politician she ran a brilliant
leadership campaign and i'm absolutely
delighted that she's decided to back me
and become part of my team it's
fantastic and i think everybody
around this room knows that we need all
the best players on the pitch in the
conservative party you know we need to
win the next election and what i am all
about is making sure we unite the party
that we move forward with a really clear
conservative vision and i'm absolutely
delighted to have penny on board and of
course when you talk about players on
the pitch in your potential future
cabinet may that include your other
opponent rishi sunak if you are
successful in this race i thought you
were going to talk about the lionesses
when you started talking about players
on the pitch
as well
i'm huge fan of them and i think they
showed tremendous spirit last night you
know when it was it was a difficult it
was a difficult match of course i would
have richie sunak as part of my team
he's a fantastic guy we need all of our
best talent on the pitch
and i have huge respect for him now
let's talk about your slogan which is
trusted to deliver you've been in the
cabinet since 2014 and since then you've
done lots of different portfolios i
think six cabinet jobs giving you only
five cabinet jobs the next one is
domestic achievements from that
in those roles so
lots of people said
after we left the eu
that we wouldn't be able to get as good
trade deals as the eu had in fact i got
all of them in record time and i got an
even better deal with japan new deals
with australia and new zealand started
off the process of vinidia started off
the process with trans-pacific
partnership i'm very proud of what we
achieved at the department of trade we
showed the massive opportunities that
were after brexit and what i want to do
as prime minister
is being able to unleash the full
opportunities things like solvency ii
method changing our procurement laws so
they're fair for british companies and i
think so that would be a huge
achievement
one of the things one of the things that
makes me proudest
is the work i did to secure the release
of nazaneen and anusha
nazini
had been in jail in iran on and off for
six years
and again
i was told that this would be difficult
that this would be impossible but i
found a new way of doing things i worked
with the team at the foreign office and
we succeeded in bringing her and a new
show home and i just remember
waiting at bryson orton in the middle of
the night and her coming off the plane
to see her young daughter and husband
and that was one of the best moments of
my life
[Music]
that is why i'm in politics to make a
difference i really felt on that
occasion i made a difference and
the third thing i would highlight
is the work i've done on the northern
ireland project called bill again people
said that this was a difficult challenge
that i'd been handed a poison chalice i
got it just before christmas and i did
say to david frost thanks for the
christmas present david uh you've given
me the whole christmas to spot up on
these negotiations
and
we didn't get where we wanted with the
eu and peace in northern ireland is
incredibly important to me the belfast
good friday agreement is incredibly
important i remember what it was like
before that agreement was done and how
the troubles in northern ireland you
know affected all of us
all of us they are part of our family so
sorting out that has been really
important getting the support of that
bill in parliament again lots of people
said it would be impossible that
parliament wouldn't support it
they made claims it was illegal but it's
not illegal it's absolutely right that
we protect the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of our country and
that we protect the belfast good friday
agreement now on the
on the latter point about the norman
protocol situation now that bill is
making its way to parliament at the
moment would you have any reservations
at all in triggering those measures to
collapse parts of the protocol given the
fact we could see a retaliation from the
eu we've got a cost of living in crisis
inflation is going to be rampant if they
were then to raise trade tariffs that
could make the situation a lot worse
well they would be completely wrong to
do this because the way we have
done the bill is to create a green and a
red channel which helps protect the
european single market at the same time
as protecting trade between northern
ireland and great britain and that is
vitally important currently the belfast
good friday agreement is being
undermined
the relations between east and west are
being undermined and i will not allow
that to happen under my watch i will
proceed with the bill i've always been
clear that i would rather get a
negotiated solution with the eu but i
think we've learned from history that
there's only one thing the eu
understands and that is strength and i
am strong enough to make this happen
we talked about symptoms
which of course is just 15 miles up the
road from here and you said that you're
the candidate who could win i think the
blue wall the red wall and cornwall you
said as well but that was a silly pun i
apologize for my for my dad jokes i'm
sure the call of people here will
forgive you one day but there is polling
out that suggests if you were facing
kiyosama in a general election you would
lose so what evidence have you got
having never fought a national campaign
that you can win
i've seen the opposite polls which said
i would win uh against pearce
[Applause]
but one thing i don't believe in and i
frankly think there's too much of being
going on under successive prime
ministers is worrying about polls
worrying about focus groups what we need
to do as conservatives we need to do
what's right we need to do what is right
for people we need to deliver on our
promises and that is why we will gain
their trust
and deliver the next election so the
idea we should be looking for the same
column in the financial times would be
worrying about the polls we shouldn't be
worrying about that we should be
worrying about delivering broadband and
a mobile phone signal here in devon we
should be worried about making sure
our farmers can produce fantastic people
you know we should be worried about
facing down vladimir putin and ensure
the ukrainians win that's what we should
care about
campbell
moved the chief whip out of number 12
downing street and he moved the press
office in just to show you my priorities
i'm going to move the cheap whip
he's actually not the worst he's one of
the nice ones he's one of the nice ones
but my
my priority is delivering
what the public have voted for
in line with our conservative values of
rewarding people who work hard do the
right thing set up businesses
those are the people that i am working
for not the press not the pollsters not
the media
now
we if you become prime minister we are
obviously going to face a very difficult
cut six months ahead with obviously the
potential energy price cap going to be
raised and inflation is still going to
be very high and one thing that we've
seen is a growing move of civil
disobedience there's a campaign called
don't pay those people say they're going
to refuse to pay their energy bills
later this year what would be your
policy response to that
well my response on energy yes it is
partly fracking and we should allow we
should allow fracking
we should we should allow fracking we
should allow fracking where local
communities support it and you say
things will take a long time
they will take less time under my
government because i will pass primary
legislation to get things done the fact
is road projects rail projects
infrastructure projects are taking too
long in this country they go through
two-minute phases the planning system is
too slow we need to get on and we need
spades in the ground before the next
election and i'm determined to use our
majority in parliament to deliver that
i am getting on with your question uh
i will also make sure we exploit all of
the gas in the north sea and we make
sure we use that to bolster our domestic
energy supply i'll move forward faster
with nuclear uh including major nuclear
stations but also small modular reactors
which are produced in derby in a major a
major opportunity for our country as
well and what i am immediately
announcing
is having a moratorium on the green
energy level which will immediately save
money on people's bills as well as
immediately
reducing people's taxes because i
believe it is completely wrong that at
this time when families are struggling
with fuel bills that we have put up
their taxes i spoke out against it at
cabinet in the time i'm still i'm still
against it i mean on the issue of civil
disobedience more generally
i am concerned about militant trade
unions
i will reach out
the trade union time wasting that is
currently going on whitehall at the
taxpayer's expense and i'll also
legislate to make sure we protect
essential services including essential
use of our railways it's completely
wrong that people who work hard are
penalized and can't get into work
meanwhile train drivers who already very
well paid are causing havoc
now
we have a few minutes left before we go
back to the audience that comes my
favorite part which is the quick fire
personal round here
liz trust which opposition politician do
you admire the most
um
i think rosie duffield because she stood
up against the ludicrous lobby in the
labour party who denied the fact that
women are women and she's been prepared
to stand up for her beliefs
number two
are you a person of faith and do you
practice religion regularly so i i share
the values of the
christian faith and the church of
england but i'm not a regularly
practicing
religious person
what's the one public perception about
you that is most
they're all true
[Applause]
the best non-political book you've read
recently
i do like rebecca by daphne de mario
there we are
if you weren't a politician what would
you be
um
believe me it would be less stress and
probably probably more money as well but
uh the
what would i be i actually absolutely
love food so i'd love to be a food
critic and a food writer
and finally
do you have any doubt about your ability
to fulfill the role of prime minister
no i don't
i've i've
been foreign secretary i've been trade
secretary i've held other roles in the
cabinet i know there will be tough times
but i also know that i can deal with
difficult situations
i can get the job done and i'm
completely determined and resolute
and one last bonus one and without
thinking of fields of wheat too much
what is the most embarrassing thing
you've ever done
i mean obviously
yes my my daughters will be watching
this and i absolutely am not going to
say
you so much for being such a good sport
now let's go to audience questions if
you look around you will see people in
the white hoodies who've got the
microphones so if you want to raise your
hand we'll try and get through as many
of them as we can and let's go to the
gentleman here uh in the uh lucia tell
us your name please
thank you my name is john levinson and
as many many
members of the party across the country
live in the countryside and many of all
party members would like to know if you
will allow government time within this
park current parliament to repeal that
dreadful 2005 hunting act which is
divisive and does nothing for animal
welfare and
it
poorly affects the rural economy thank
you very much well
you might know you might know that i'm
an mp in norfolk which is a fantastic
place for country sports we have a very
strong shooting industry i'm very very
supportive of country sports
but i remember
being a minister under david cameron's
government and looking at this issue and
i think opening pandora's box could
possibly make the situation worse for
people who enjoy country sports so
whilst i share
uh your love of
rural pastimes and i'm the strong
supporter of all of the
fantastic conservation work uh the
shooting industry does
i i think we've got to be very careful
about opening that box
thank you
what i would say about me is you'll
always get an honest answer and i will
never make promises i can't keep and
i've never made promises in any job i've
done that i can't follow through on and
i know
i've been there i know how difficult
that one is right let's get some more
questions the gentleman here
with the white shirt thank you yes
i think it was two days ago as you
mentioned i think in an article the
daily telegraph sorry
um that uh
that you you were more interested in
leveling up in the rural community that
perhaps of the people mentioned in the
past
we are my friend and i are from the
father's west constituency and we call
it ice but we prefer to know it's west
coal in the isles of silly
if you come here today by train that
we've taken you two hours from london
already taking me three hours from penn
state's
when are we going to get the kind of
infrastructure investment that makes our
lives on equal terms to the rest of the
country
the issue at the moment
is the treasury green book
has
this thing called a benefit cost ratio
and essentially what it means
is if you already have a lot of
infrastructure and capital you get more
so this is why more and more tube lines
end up getting built in london while
cities get the fiber roll out first
i don't believe that is what we should
be doing i want to rip up that rule book
and change it because i think it's
important to help those communities with
the worst infrastructure first so my
policy would be helping
rural areas level up and get that
infrastructure we know and if you want
to be a farmer now or you want to run a
small business in devon or cornwall you
need the internet it's not an optional
service you need it and it's you can't
even get a mobile phone signal in vast
ways of the area so
but the thing about me
is i'm prepared to challenge the
orthodoxy and this these rules have not
changed for years they haven't changed
uh that's not quite true
ripped up the green book a couple of
years ago when he was saying why hasn't
it changed
because i haven't seen any change in the
last two and a half years sebastian i
you know i'm in a rural constituency too
i've been campaigning for an upgrade in
my trade line for the last 15 years and
it is simply not happening and it is
because the rules are still not right
well here's a question for you one of
your favorite contenders
talked about breaking up the treasury do
you think the treasury should be broken
up
well i wouldn't want to give him any
advance warning
[Applause]
i do think the treasury needs to change
and it has been a block on progress you
know why haven't we got things like
solvency ii
and method changed these are the things
that would unleash investment including
into our rural communities in the
southwest we haven't changed them since
brexit and we need to get on with it and
this is partly about challenging not
just the treasury orthodoxy but the
white wall of the doxie and getting
things done and i'm prepared to break
all eggs to make the oven lift
500 people in the treasury who enjoy
breakfast now let's go over here there's
a lady just here who's sticking her
hands up
i think you might have a green top on
there
where does all the money come from
where's all the money going to come from
i mean there's some great promises some
great
pledges and some things i totally
totally believe in especially helping
people who are struggling but where is
the money going to come from is it going
to put us into debt
thank you very much
the answer is
the money
the money is going to come from
thriving enterprises thriving businesses
and economic growth
that is where we as conservatives
believe that money comes from and that's
how we have a successful prosperous
country and the fact is if we tax
businesses too much
if we tax people too much and we've
currently got the highest tax rates for
70 years in our country we will throttle
that growth
and we're currently predicted to have a
recession next year
so my view is business as usual carrying
on with these high taxes raising taxes
on corporations which is the proposal uh
currently
will throttle off growth and it will
mean less money coming into the
exchequer and less revenue coming
together i mean look gordon brown makes
a very good argument
from a labor point of view for high tax
inspect but my view is not a
conservative policy we believe in
enterprise we believe in people keeping
more of their own money we believe in
rewarding people who work hard and do
the right thing and we're currently
if you look at our debt levels
our debt levels are lower than the debt
levels of canada and the
debt levels of japan than the debt
levels of the united states and we've
just been through a major economic shock
i think it is a mistake
to try and pay it all back
next year and balance the books and
completely throttle our economy and no
other no other g7 country is doing that
no other country is raising taxes at the
moment are you at all concerned though
that i think it was page seven of the
2019 conservative manifesto said that
debt would be lower at the end of the
part of the beginning of course we've
been through the covered pandemic that
has raised debt quite significantly but
this does feel like not the sort of
thing that liz trusts as the cameron
government
the long-term economic plan bringing
down the deficit that was your message
then says ramping
but i think we should have done more
long-term reform particularly in things
like social care i think it was wrong to
cut the social care budget
and then we're now suffering the
consequences of that so not everything
the government does is perfect and not
everything every government does
is perfect but
what we're facing with covid is a one in
a hundred year event
you know
the second world war is a major event we
didn't suddenly decide we had to pay
back all the debt the next week so i
don't i don't agree with this argument
that we have to pay back the very high
costs of covet
harming ordinary people who are
currently struggling with fuel bills and
food and food bills and also
making our economy uncompetitive so what
we're currently talking about is raising
our corporation tax to 10 basis points
higher than the islands
and the same level as francis and i
don't think that is what we want a
post-brexit competitive
you know and of course
of course sebastian i want to reform the
public sector and i'm going to lay out a
10-year plan of how we get rid of lots
of quangos we've got 500 of them how we
slim down white ball how we cut out
bureaucracy but i'm a realist i
recognize this takes time at the same
time we need to unleash the potential in
our economy and we haven't done enough
yet and i've talked about fisheries i've
talked about food and farming i've
talked about infrastructure these are
all things we need to get on delivering
because the fact is we've had low growth
for two decades and simply carrying on
with the same policy is going to result
in more low growth so my vision is bold
it is
different
but it is needed and i believe that
people voted in 2019 because they wanted
something new they didn't want more of
the same right i'm going to turn around
behind you now to try and get some
people here uh it's good for the
gentleman just down here at the front of
her
potentially a black jumper it could be
blue depending on the lights here
my question is about the online safety
bill which is slightly different so uh
as kelly bannock said it's not fit for
purpose and a danger to free speech
what is your opinion of that
yes would you scrap the online safety
bill
well what what i believe about online
safety
is we do need to protect the under 18s
from some of the content online i have a
16 year old daughter and a 13 year old
daughter and frankly i'm worried about
some of the stuff they see i'm also
worried about young teenagers being on
social networking sites and we know it
has had a bad effect particularly on
girls mental health so i think we do
need to do more
to tackle those issues online
but when people are grown adults i do
believe they should be able to speak
freely i do believe they should be able
to freely communicate and i will make
sure
that we do what we need in the online
harms bill to make sure we're not
affecting free speech and we're
defending free speech but i think it is
important that we do protect the under
18. so you would be amending the online
bill as it currently stands to change
those elements to do with things that
will be making sure
that it protects free speech
with all my friends in the conservative
party to make sure they're happy as well
right including including the gentleman
um
do you regret any of your support for
the three lockdowns within government
because of course there's been many
policy areas that you are part of the
government the national insurance advice
for example which you've now come out
again so privately do you think lockdown
was a bad idea well every single chance
i was given the opportunity to express a
view i was on the thinking of doing less
rather more on lockdowns and opening up
the economy earlier the fact is i wasn't
part of the key cable committee i was
the international trade secretary i was
spending my time trying to get all these
trade deals done
i wasn't really a core part of that
coded decision making and often frankly
it was presented as a theta complete uh
as the french would say to the to the
wider capital and look when i have
objected to government policy
in the case of national insurance i did
i said it would be a mistake to raise
taxes i said we didn't need to we could
afford it within our current spending
envelope under my plans it will still be
the case that debt is falling within
three years
and i thought it was a mistake at the
time but i i'm a loyal person i respect
cabinet collective responsibility
and governments don't work if
everybody's just
talking off offline all the time i know
it makes you happy as a journalist said
when people sort of leak stuff to you
but i can tell you one of my criteria
for the people who would be in my
cabinet if i was prime minister is i
don't want people who leak and breathe i
want people who have those discussions
internally
and then
and then
behave behave um behave properly
externally
i can tell you the two other criteria as
well if you like
and the second is they've got to be able
to get things done and challenge the
orthodoxy right
one last kind of question is uh let's do
it
should we go on this side apologies who
was who was shouting on this side all
right i'll go for this gentleman down
here
hi mario rossi from darwin and someone
said
what are you going to do to get
scotland on the boards because i'm sick
to death hearing about nicholas sturgeon
trying to break up the unions
of the united kingdom have weakened over
the past 12 years of conservative
government and if you look at northern
ireland or scotland independence is very
much um a question again and
what is your plan to reverse that
[Music]
anyway
and
i feel like i'm the child of the union
that i really believe we are a family
and we're better together and i think
the best thing to do with nicholas
sturgeon is ignore her i think
[Applause]
i'm sorry an attention seeker
that's what she is and what we need to
do
is show the people of scotland northern
ireland and wales what we are delivering
for them and making sure that all of our
government policies apply right across
the united kingdom you know i was very
proud to lift the whiskey taps and i
don't think i've ever been more popular
than i was in maiden's bar in edinburgh
the night that i was there with a bunch
of whiskey distillers he said this has
made a huge big difference to their
business
it was now 25 cheaper for them to export
their fantastic whiskey to the united
states and that is the kind of thing we
need to be there we need to be showing
what we're delivering and you know
nicholas sturgeon can
sort of carry on talking about an
independence referendum we had the
referendum in 2014. it was agreed it was
once in a generation
i didn't realize his generation happened
within 10 years that doesn't make any
sense so we've got a caller out on that
but at the same time really delivering
for scotland so some of the policies i'm
talking about the investment zones the
freeports we need to make sure they're
delivered in scotland too that's an
thank you so much for all those
questions everyone i'm sorry we didn't
get to more with them but thank you very
much for putting those forward and
please stand liz trust
so we now have a little bit of
changeover and as we have obviously um
our next candidate and so ladies and
gentlemen please give a very large round
of applause for the right honourable
rishi sunac mp
thank you very much well welcome mr
sooner back to the stage um let's begin
with your big announcement which was on
the front page newspapers today about uh
about tax cuts
in the future when you launched your
leadership campaign you said the
conservative party faced a choice
between reality and fairy tale economics
now what's not a fairy tale about a tax
cut six years away that's predicated on
a fifth general election victory you
said was going to be a solid problem
well
the difference is my plan is one that is
one that's paid for and that's the big
difference and it's one that comes in
after we've got a grip of inflation now
this is not something i've just come up
with today as chancellor i put in place
a tax strategy which will deliver in
this parliament the first income tax cut
that we've had in almost 16 years in
this country and that was in my plans
and i paid for it by making sure that
we're going to be controlled with public
spending and we're going to grow the
economy and as prime minister i want to
go further than that and keep cutting
income because it's the best
demonstration we have as a party to the
working people of this country that
we're on their side that we want them to
work hard and we want to reward that
hard work put more money into their
pockets that's what conservative
governments do and that's what i'm going
to deliver
why did this idea just come at this
point in the campaign because some of
your opponents have said that you've
done screeching u-turns flip-flopping
because you announced the v80 energy cut
last week this tax cut now the beginning
of this campaign you weren't really
thinking about this sort of thing what
changed the beginning of this campaign
this campaign's only just getting
started
i mean
we've got weeks of this ballots are just
only arriving this week right so let's
not get carried away we're right at the
beginning of this thing now we have to
differentiate two things
how do we help people in the southwest
and across the country
with the immediate challenges they're
facing with the cost of living and in
that context it's absolutely right that
we go further than i announced as
chancellor because the situation has
changed the energy bills are going to be
higher and the easiest thing we can do
at this point given we're pretty close
to the autumn is to cut v80 on fuel
that's why i'm going to do that but
that's temporary and for a specific
purpose that's very different
from me standing up here and promising
all of you 30 40 i think at last count
50 billion pounds worth of permanent
unfunded tax cuts because that isn't
conservative and that would be risky in
the environment that we're in so it's
right to provide short-term help for
people with a cost of living but it's
also right to give all of you and the
country a sense of where i want to take
the economy and where i want to take it
is in a direction where we're being
disciplined on public services we're
reforming them not just putting more
cash into them we're growing the economy
by doing radically things differently
with business taxation and brexit
opportunities and then we're using that
growth to cut taxes responsibly and over
time and cut income tax because we want
to reward hard work that's my plan
now in this contest
would you describe yourself as a change
or continuity candidate and are you a
doomsayer or a gloom sir at all as
you're cued by your successor in the
treasury i believe well i i'm definitely
the change count
and the reason is if you look at my
political career
well
so it's hard to say i'm the one that's
been around a long time but in any case
if you look at my political career at
the crunch moment
when we have thought about doing things
differently where have i been when it
came to the brexit referendum when i was
told that my career would be over before
it had begun
when we did have a bunch of doomsday
predictions which i remember certain
people were campaigning on where was i
on that divide i supported change i
supported brexit and i believe in my
principles there and i believe in my
principles now
now
one of the policies you put forward and
quite recently was to do with house
building and essentially you said we're
not going to be building houses on the
green belt now my generation and it's
quite hard to believe they're still
still vaguely young but uh the under 35
generation are really struggling to buy
houses and fundamentally this is a
supply problem and doesn't your policy
which has been criticized by some
center-right fingertime just make the
supply problem even worse how are people
of my generation ever going to buy a
house under prime minister sooner
first of all it's absolutely right and
there'll be people in this audience who
want to do that and many of us sitting
here tonight will remember what it feels
like we remember how magical it was when
we got that set of keys to our first
flat house and then we started to
improve it and make it our own we maybe
got married and built our family there
that is an incredibly conservative dream
that we need to fulfill and right now
too many young people can't do it so
it's absolutely right to answer the
question because if we are going to
protect our green spaces and we're not
going to impose top-down planning
targets on our local authorities how are
we going to do it well we need to do a
few things we need to make sure we
unlock brownfield land across the
country there are about a million homes
that we can build on brownfield indeed
one of those centre-right think tanks
you mentioned wrote a very good report
about that so if the government steps in
to remediate that land we can build
houses there the second thing we need to
do is in our urban areas largely often
controlled by labor authorities they're
not building enough our urban areas are
not dense enough if you look at our
cities versus all european cities so we
can improve it there
and then the third thing we need to do
in terms of supply is something that
isn't particularly british sounding and
that's
and the reality is most other developed
countries use modular housing and they
do it because it is high quality
it is faster and it is cheaper
now
lastly because i know this is an
important question i'm going to give you
an extra bit of detail it's not just
about supply because that will help but
what i know many of you in this audience
will have is children or grandchildren
who have a great job
and actually have a great credit history
because they've been paying rent
and they could actually afford the
mortgage payments and in fact the
mortgage payments may even be lower than
their rent payments but what they don't
have is the money for the big deposit
because it now takes just far too long
to save up for that deposit so as
chancellor i created a new 95 mortgage
for first-time buyers and it's working
really well it's getting the young
people on the housing ladder and as
prime minister i want to turbo charge
that policy because if we can work with
the banks and make that a new first-time
buyer mortgage work it means younger
people can get on the housing ladder and
have that magical feeling that we all
had when we got our first home that's
what i want to do
now i want to give to you uh the same
question i put to lisa earlier about
tifton hollington just 15 miles up the
road here because that by-election loss
was a historic loss for the conservative
party and i think much like your
opponent you've also said you're the
only candidate who can win the blue wall
and the red ball again if you've not led
and fought a national election campaign
before what is the evidence you can win
back time
well first of all i'm sure there are a
lot of people here in the audience who
are campaigning there and i came down to
support you can i just say thank you to
you because you guys did an
extraordinary job in very difficult
circumstances from westminster and
actually we all know you an enormous
vote of thanks quite frankly so first of
all thank you
so
much
when it comes back to winning tivoli
there's the immediate issue of fixing
the school and that's one that we'll
need to get on and deliver at some point
soon because i think people want to see
change there but more broadly if you
look at rural areas you look at liberal
leaning areas what is it we need to do
well look like many of you i live in an
incredibly rural part of the country and
rural communities have particular
challenges you know whether it's bus
services whether it's getting broadband
out to rural communities to spread
opportunity whether it's making
transport infrastructure work properly
and whether as i discussed earlier it's
about backing farms and making sure the
trade deals we sign are not quote
unquote one-sided as the nfu
decried one of our trade deals but
actually work for british farmers so we
need to get the rural community to first
of all realize that they can trust a
conservative government and everything
about
[Music]
and in areas like this when i was
knocking on doors and i was speaking to
people what people did not like that in
their view government was not run
properly it was not run seriously and it
was not run with decency and integrity
and that is the change that i want to
bring as prime minister
the name you didn't enter there of
course is boris johnson who was prime
minister um and i think you may be
saying that essentially some of the
issues with his government the reason
you lost that by-election you've said
you've explained the ethical problems
that you had towards the end of that
government but also disagreements in
fiscal policy so why didn't you quit
earlier
because i'm instinctively wanted to try
and make it work i wanted to give him
the benefit of the doubt for as long as
i could and i wanted to keep serving the
british people but it got to a point
where the government found itself on the
wrong side of yet another ethical divide
that was hard for me to defend combined
with my well-documented differences on
economic policy and so along with 60
other members of parliament i took the
difficult decision to leave government
because i thought that both our party
and our country deserve better and
that's the change that we now need to
bring now just before we come to the
personal quickfire
you mentioned trade deals before and
there's been some commentary i think
from sort of people that lie to a
campaign about um about the australian
trade deal which had particular things
to do with farmers and saying that this
shows this trust's remainer roots and
which i think was probably quite
surprising to people who have seen what
this trust has been saying about
do you think it's a problem with the
trade deals we've negotiated towards
agriculture would you like to overturn
the trade deal with australia because
it's not good enough for farmers we
can't rip up treaties that we've we've
already
is that we shouldn't be rushing to sign
trade deals as quickly as possible we
should be taking the time to get them
right and we should make sure that they
work for british farmers it's not rocket
science in that regard because our
farming communities are incredibly
important to our country i see that
every week when i go home to north
yorkshire my neighbor is a dairy farm
the nfu tells me i represent more
farmers than any other constituency and
i certainly represent more sheep than
people where i am so this is something
that i acutely feel every week and i
want to make sure that we run a
government that is respectful of rural
communities that's supporting them that
is prioritizing food security and food
production and backing our farmers
that's here at home and it's with trade
deals and that's the change that i will
bring right
[Applause]
which opposition politician do you ever
admire the most oh gosh right um well
probably let's try not to down them by
outing them now so rather than give you
one who is currently there i'll give you
my favorite one that is no longer with
us and that's hugh gateskill and uh he
was a labour chancellor in the 50s
there we go
as me i have a picture of him up in my
uh and study it when i was in downing
street alongside michael lawson and uh
william gladstone the reason i chose
gateskill because even though he was a
labour chancellor here were some of his
policy positions while the labour party
wanted to ban the bomb and do nuclear
disarmament he was in favor of a nuclear
deterrent well before tony blair thought
about it he wanted to abolish clause 4.
and then also while the rest of the
labour party was headlong into more
european integration he remained very
skeptical of the european project so as
far as labour politicians go i thought
he was pretty sound
yeah
number two
are you a person of faith and do you
practice religion regularly yes and
and that's how we raised our kids and as
i'm saying just a few weeks ago i was
back at my temple in southampton where i
grew up because every year we have a
family prayer day where we took lunch
and served to the community
[Applause]
before about it's this idea of
continuity versus change
and you know actually i've spent my life
wanting to do things differently i'm not
in this just to manage things i'm in
this to radically transform things and
we talked about that with brexit where i
took the side of the argument was about
doing something great doing something
different being bold you saw that from
me during the pandemic i ripped up the
rule book in a matter of weeks to design
programs interventions policies that
this country had never seen before and
made sure that we protected people's
jobs and businesses when it came to the
lockdown that people wanted to do last
christmas with omnicron i came back from
a business trip abroad and i wanted to
stop that from happening and i'm glad i
did with others make sure that we didn't
walk into another lockdown
[Applause]
[Music]
yes of course i want to be responsible
in managing inflation that's a sensible
conservative thing to do but gosh do i
want to be radical about how we grow
this economy as chancellor i set up
freeports it's one of the few things
visibly that we can see as a benefit
from brexit i want to reform financial
services regulation i want to make sure
this is the best place in the world to
innovate i want to reform the corporate
tax system and actually hopefully we'll
get on to this in the q a
liz trust's policies on corporate
taxation are exactly the failed treasury
orthodoxy of the last 10 years which
hasn't worked i want to change it and
grow the economy
what is the best non-political book
you've read recently
oh uh well actually if i re-read i
reread one of my favorite books with my
kids and that was going solo by roald
dahl
if you weren't a politician what would
you be
oh uh well
my bucket list of life's ambitions well
when i was a kid i wanted to be in a
star wars movie um so that's probably
not a sensible thing to do but i'm a
massive football fan i'm from
southampton and if i would get to be
able to
[Applause]
[Music]
do you have any doubt about your ability
to fulfill the role of prime minister
no i would be sitting here if i didn't
right i mean obviously these are
difficult jobs obviously we face
challenging times but i would have not
put myself forward and ask all of you to
support me if i didn't think that i was
up to the task of meeting those
challenges and leading our country
forward to a brighter future i
passionately believe that i can do that
i can do it all for you very well and
most importantly i can go and smash
kirsten and the labour party and the
liberals at the next level
what is the most embarrassing thing
you've ever done oh gosh
um well certainly recently some of you
might have seen that i
these days it's amazing
right now let's open some questions in
the audience once again and see the
people with the white hoodies and we'll
get around and i'm going to start over
here because i didn't come over this end
last time oh yes i'll do i'll do my best
don't worry um
criteria of value for money when it
comes to transport and infrastructure we
don't hit that target so what will you
do for west dorset for buses
this is the greek question
about the fact that for many years the
treasury's formula
has always favored london and the
southeast so what would you do to help
west dawson yes well look
if you don't mind i'm going to stand so
i can just see all of you so you're
actually right about rural communities
and it's not just about transport
actually it's about schools as well so
like you i represent an area where you
have dozens and dozens of very small
village primary schools right and the
funding formula for those doesn't work
properly because it assumes that they
can all be bigger and more efficient but
that doesn't work when you're trying to
deal with four-year-olds so you're right
that we need to make sure our funding
formulas deal with rural areas and i've
already started to change that when i
was a local government minister for
local council funding for things like
social care uh transportation as well
actually we do it in a way that is
better and we need to do it more for
schools we made half of the progress
before i'd like to finish the job so
your broader point is absolutely right
and if there are things to change of
course i'll change them because i
represent a rural area like yours and we
need to make sure that the voice of
rural britain is heard loudly and
clearly down in westminster because not
often they get it wrong
[Applause]
the gentleman here with the
uh hello my name
question is not about farming
um
there are 32 percent of the
workforce in the uk
is now working in public service in
government
32
so we're seeing an increase in backlogs
and a decrease in efficiencies
in the us in the united states they've
started using something called
software automation and they've achieved
12 billion dollars in savings and save
millions of hours of work
will you support and mandate
the use of such technologies if you
become pronounced slipping down the
public sector
you are absolutely right and i think
mandating is probably a strong word but
when i talked about being bold and
reforming public services that's exactly
what we need to do and that's what my
background will be a great place to
actually do for all of us and the first
place we need to do it actually is with
the nhs
because right now we've got this massive
problem with the backlog
and as they've already done in some
trusts we can use software automation
and ai to massively rip through all the
triaging and processing of them and
clear up the list and that's going to
improve processing time i tell you the
other thing though we need to be bolder
because if we're going to reform public
services we can't just sit on our hands
we need to be prepared to do some things
differently and this is about the
radicalism i was talking about before
which is why actually for too long all
of you know millions and millions of
people miss their hospital and gp
appointments and it's wrong because
they're depriving people of the care
that they need and actually i'm prepared
to be tough on that for the first time
because if we can reduce the number of
missed appointments have people cancel
them in advance
without spending a penny more of any of
your money we've suddenly created lots
more health care for everyone so that's
the kind of reforming deal that i will
bring to it and the technology will
absolutely
[Applause]
neither your trust have mentioned at any
point that i can recall
is mental health
now i have a 16 year old daughter
who four years ago
we suspected of the doctors suspected
she may have autism
we tried to get some diagnosis and we
were told it would take at least two
years to see somebody to get a diagnosis
now for
a child that's appalling
we were in the fortunate position that
we could go privately she was diagnosed
with autism she had to come out of
mainstream schooling
four years ago since then we've been
unable to get any support for her
or our family now we're lucky we can
afford some private help but what about
the vast majority of people who cannot
afford to get a private diagnosis
private help what will you do
for mental health in particular for
children
jeremy my my two girls are a little bit
younger than yours so i can imagine how
difficult and challenging that's been
over the last couple of years to deal
with and actually i was going to pay
tribute to jeremy hunt because jeremy
was the first health secretary who
finally made sure that the nhs
prioritized mental health gave it a ring
fence budget and got the focus on it in
a way that it hadn't happened before i
think jeremy deserves enormous credit
for doing that well before um i was even
an mp but the job is not done as your
experience shows and we've got further
to go and particularly for young people
you know what i'd like to see is more
mental health provision in educational
settings to identify problems earlier
and we've started doing some of that but
there's more we can do but also we need
to make sure that we stop the problem at
sorts and one thing that's increasingly
clear and this will be different for
your daughters who's coming from autism
but one of the growing reasons that
children and adolescents are suffering
from mental health is because of what
they see online and what they're exposed
to online and there'll be many parents
and grandparents here like me with young
daughters especially who will be
horrified at what might happen when
their kids are using their ipads and
that's why i think we need to crack on
with the online safety bill and we need
to really make sure we clamp down on
this pernicious content because yes we
need to get you the support you need for
your daughter but we also make
[Applause]
as it stands about its free speech
provisions yeah there's a very
particular bit of the bill that talks
about legal but harmful content and
that's the bit that just needs looking
at to make sure that we are not overly
infringing on free speech governments
generally should be in the business of
saying this is illegal this is not legal
with a clear line so that gray area just
we need to make sure that we get off all
right let's go i'm doing a little
clockwise thing around the window
right the lady there just about three
from the back thank you
good evening my name is claudette
um and i've listened very carefully to
what you've both had to say
you've both
said that you would like to reward hard
work
you're interested in rural areas
and one area of growth that hasn't been
mentioned
is our elderly population
and that comes hard on
your comments about social care
it needs to be fixed sir
i'm retired
and i am a baby boomer
i went back to work because i spent my
life
working in elderly care
when the pandemic hit i'm no hero i
wanted to help
i work for a small company
and i've got over 40 years experience in
all aspects of healthcare
especially dementia
elderly care
i'm getting the question is are you
listening
to the state
that elderly care is in we need help now
[Applause]
stream for social care because during
the pandemic we all saw some of the
frailties of the system exposed and we
don't want to repeat those and it was
very clear that there'll be lots of
counsellors here in the room i'm sure
tonight who grapple with this on a daily
and weekly basis and that's why i did
something that even though it was
difficult i believe it was the right
thing to do because if we're going to
have any hope of properly reforming
social care we do need to put some more
funding in and that's what i did as
chancellor for you and for everyone else
who relies on it we need to also make
sure that we improve the quality of
social care provision the people that
are working hard in that sector don't
feel that they're rewarded they're
valued enough and part of the funding
will go to improving their careers
providing all the support and training
that they need to feel valued and
fulfilled
but also we need to reform things as i
was saying before right so we need to
get the nhs to join up better with local
councils at the local level we can't
have the nhs keep gobbling up all the
money and social care being the poor
cousin because that's not going to work
and to the question over here we need to
fix the funding formulas because in
rural areas like this the population of
elderly people is growing far faster
than it is in other areas and the
funding for the southwest needs to
reflect that in fact the south west is
probably the area where the elderly
population is growing the fastest in the
uk at the moment so those are all the
things i want to do for social care but
all you have to remember is when it came
to it i did something that was
incredibly difficult and personally
difficult and politically challenging
for me because i believe i want to fix
social care and if we don't do it we
won't win the next election and millions
of people will not get the care that
they need
hi my name is eddie i'm a student here
at exeter
exeter has some of the world's leading
climate scientists many of whom i've
spoken to
um one chapter in particular uh tim
linton the director of the global
systems institute he co-authored a paper
saying that in a best case scenario a
best case scenario
by 2070 one and a half billion people
are going to be living in areas that are
too hot for habitation
i'm very concerned with the trend that
the conservative government is taking
deporting illegal refugees to rwanda
many of these people are fleeing from
war-torn regions and climate-ravaged
regions
so
what is your response should we have
compassion for the people that are going
to be moving to europe going to be
moving into north america
away from the topics which are going to
become uninhabitable
so if the question is about migration
let me say that it's very unequivocally
that our country is unbelievably special
our country throughout us history has
compassionately welcomed people like my
family
because this is the place which gives
refuge to those fleeing persecution and
it integrates them into our society
better than any country in the world and
it's something that i and i'm sure every
single person
alongside that it's also absolutely
right that we have control over our
borders it is not right in this day and
age that we cannot control who is coming
here what they're doing here and the
risk and the threat that they pose to us
and indeed the cost because all of you
right now are forking out five million
quid a day in hotel costs for people who
have come here illegally and that has to
stop
so
i won't in the interest of time if
you've got five minutes tonight there's
a video on my website with a very
detailed ten point plan about how we're
going to do this but i do believe in the
rwanda policy but it's not good enough
to just announce these things we need a
government that can actually make them
work and that's what i'm going to do and
that's going to mean some legal changes
we'll need to make i will make but at
the end of the day we must have control
over our borders that is completely
consistent with us remaining a
compassionate and tolerant country that
welcomes people from syria afghanistan
ukraine hong kong and indeed my family
60 years ago that's who we are in
britain and that's what we will always
be
[Applause]
that in order to achieve change it
requires both policy
and character
and that includes the character of the
leadership contenders but also their top
teams and that's very important to us
members
so in light of that um would you be able
to say whether you would invite gavin
williamson to join your cabinet
well look i i don't think it would be
appropriate i don't think it would be
appropriate for me to start talking
about individual colleagues like that
about jobs that's not right and i think
that i think hopefully you'll understand
that but i continue my approach to
building a team and my approach to
building a team in government is to draw
on all the talents and traditions of our
party and as you saw in this leadership
contest we've got some fantastic people
at the top of the conservative party
we've got some fantastic people coming
up behind them and the challenges that
our country faces are great and we would
be letting down the british people if we
did not put our absolute best people
forward to grip those challenges so
that's the kind of team that i'm going
to build that's going to deliver for you
and it's going to deliver everyone else
in this country it's going to be a team
of unbelievably hard-working
conservatives united in our mission to
deliver for the british people and win
the next elections
[Applause]
thank you
okay we'll try and get to as many of
them as possible yes
i'd like to know uh how important
loyalty is to you because i don't feel
you were
well madam i i respectfully disagree
because i was loyal to boris johnson
[Applause]
and it wouldn't be right for the country
to have a prime minister and a
chancellor that weren't on the same page
about economic policy going into the
situation that we're going something
about leaving in that circumstance
that's the right thing to do for the
country because they deserve to have
those two people united but beyond me
and my economic policy differences we
got to a situation where the government
was on yet again the wrong side of a
very serious ethical question and you
know it wasn't just me it was 60 other
members of parliament unprecedented
resigned
thank you very much right we're getting
so sorry i'm trying to get on as many
people
those of us who haven't been able to
have our questions answered can
communicate with the two candidates is
the request you would like to ask
now sir sorry is there a question you'd
like to ask
there me thousands of pensioners under
the pension protection plan
who have absolutely no inflation
protection whatsoever
and why is that it's because the
department of work and pensions refuses
to alter the terms of the ppf
protection pension plan
and
why why is that happening in spite of
the fact that the
civil servants in the
[Applause]
which i want to address if i can
smes
when 2019 the poll came out when we won
the stocking
majority
i cried
it wasn't a crime of joy it's crying
with relief
you see
corbin's tax policy on the corporations
was to hike it up
you see i could afford that with my
family of my business because i was
already studying everything we had on
looking after my children who came here
graduated here
my question is
you are gonna put up corporation tax on
small businesses that say
why are you as a conservative
future potential prime minister ever
thinking
brilliant i'm so glad you asked martin i
am so glad you asked so we can address
this i tell you what i am doing i am
reforming our corporate tax system i'm
reforming it in a radical way to make
sure it actually delivers for all of you
in this country yes the headline rate of
corporation tax is going to go up
but you know what the rate is going up
to it's still the lowest in the g7
france italy germany canada
yes it's the lowest out of those seven
countries look at the g20 group of
countries the 20 largest economies that
we compete with in the world the rate
will still be the fourth lowest with
only i think
indonesia turkey and saudi arabia lower
than us so it is clearly an
internationally competitive rate and no
one can tell you otherwise secondly
it doesn't apply to genuinely small and
medium-sized businesses they're going to
continue paying the same very low rate
they pay today 70
of registered british companies are not
going to see an increase in their
corporation tax what we're talking about
is just the largest ones that are going
to see an increase to again an
internationally very competitive rate
and the third point you should take away
is important
we are also going to cut taxes for
business at the same time but we're
going to cut the taxes on the things
that actually make a difference to our
growth and our productivity we're going
to cut the taxes on business investment
because we have tried a failed
experiment the orthodoxy that i'm
accused of that's what i'm going to
change because that low corporation tax
rate we had has done absolutely zilch
for investment in our economy it has not
increased it is still one of the lowest
in the developed world and it accounts
for half our productivity difference
with france and germany it's because we
businesses don't invest enough why
because our tax system isn't generous
enough so this autumn i'm going to
radically cut taxes on business
investment because that's how you create
jobs and growth and better wages for
people and i'm going to cut taxes on
business investment in r d because we
talked about the future economy we want
to build the future economy we're going
to build is going to be built on
innovation and again our companies don't
invest enough in r d so we're going to
cut the taxes on that so yes i'm a
conservative yes i'm going to cut taxes
yes i want to see businesses grow but
i'm not going to stick with the failed
plans in the past i'm going to do
something radically different and that's
going to grow our economy
well ladies and gentlemen thank you so
second much leadership hustings i hope
you found it informative enlightening
and it's helped make up some minds about
who should be the next prime minister
for those of us who are watching
remotely that the next leadership
hustings will be held on wednesday in
cardiff and i'm sure we'll be hearing
plenty more from the candidate until
then thank you once again for all your
questions thank you for coming out this
evening and thank you for having me
[Applause]
um
what should you make
thank you
um
slightly devastated
can't go out
is